[Musique]
je suis christine dubon léger et je suis
danseuse chorégraphe il y à 13 ans j'ai
été stoppé net dans mon élan de
danseuses en pleine création et dans le
même temps j'étais enceinte de mon
deuxième envoi alors je me suis dit
alité pendant près de trois mois qu'il
était peut-être temps que je regarde
autrement ce que j'étais en train de
vivre
je me suis remise à marcher peu à peu
durant ma convalescence geste simple la
marche presque anthropologique
mais à marcher chaque jour dans la
nature qui m'entourent dans les marais
sauvage je me relis peu un peu avec mon
corps en mouvement mais autrement dehors
et puis dedans avec mon enfant je me
relis avec les éléments dans cette
communion avec la nature
je reçois beaucoup dans cette communion
avec mon enfant est avec moi même à
l'aube du printemps
ma fille aînée est dans la continuité de
cette naissance comme si c'était
simplement un mouvement continu
j'ai ressenti au plus profond de moi un
désir intense de retourner aux sources
du geste aux sources du souffle 1 ou sur
ceux du souffle le premier celui
peut-être qui anime la création parce
que de quelques créations s'agissait-il
qu'est ce qui m'avait animée sincèrement
et qu'est ce qui m'animait sincèrement
qu est ce qui m'habitait intimement
alors j'ai eu besoin d'aller chercher du
côté des sociétés traditionnelles et là
le hasard le hasard ces trois ans de ma
vie que j'ai passées à chercher le
hasard a guidé mes pas
chacun de mes pas aux seuils des
montagnes de l'atlas marocain au pied de
ces grandes roches rouges
et derrière ces immenses roches rouges
il y avait des femmes des milliers de
femmes qui travaillent dans un
rythme incessant chaque jour qui
oeuvrent au coeur de la nature pour leur
survie
ces femmes ce sont les femmes berbères
elle se nomme elle-même les femmes
amazir amazir c'est à dire les femmes du
peuple amazigh
c'est à dire les représentantes première
de la nature les femmes qui se dit
qu'ils se disent libre sur ce vaste
territoire
tamazgha ces femmes à masi avons
accueilli dans leur vie quotidienne
c'est comme si elle m'attendait
depuis toujours j'ai reçu elles m'ont
offert dans l'antre du groupe des femmes
cette matrice plein rempli de sont
remplies de souffle rempli de leurs voix
remplie de gens remplis du souffle qui
anime chacun de leurs gestes de travail
au quotidien
j'ai beaucoup reçu j'ai beaucoup reçu
helmand beaucoup donné et un matin tous
là
la dernière femme nomade du village du
bouddha rare dans le haut atlas est venu
me chercher et m'a emmené dans ses
montagnes ses montagnes du rouge dans
lesquelles elle avait vécu de longues
années alors nous avons marché
nous avons beaucoup marcher longtemps
et au fur et à mesure rare qu'il y avait
1 bat dynamique mais plein tranquille
s'est éloigné je la voyais de plus en
plus au loin et je l' ai vu s'arrêter au
bord d'un gouffre géant et s'est
retourné elle s'est postée la face à moi
verticale et au fur et à mesure que je
me rapprochais je remarquais que sa peau
devenait comme minérale et qu'elle
faisait corps tout entière avec laroche
qui l'enveloppait arriver moi même au
bord de ce gouffre
je voyais son châle et sa robe flotter
dans le vent le vent s'est levé et
sorties de cette immensité de gouffre
nous a enveloppé ma enveloppé dehors
tout autour de moi et à un moment donné
il c'est en vrai à l'intérieur de moi à
l'intérieur de ce ventre de femme de
mère à l'intérieur de cette danseuse qui
avait façonné son corps tant d'années
est là
ce souffle s'est posé à l'intérieur de
moi se vend entre avait aussi habité mes
deux enfants
cette matrice à nouveau mais chez moi
cette fois ci à l'intérieur de moi deux
mois et ce vent qui s'est engouffré il
est à l'intérieur de moi pour toujours à
l'infini avant minérale qui vient
habiter chacun de mes pas d'aujourd'hui
alors je me dois de transmettre au plus
grand nombre ce qui m'a été confié donc
aujourd'hui veuillez être ceux et celles
celles et ceux qui vont recevoir
veuillez vous abreuver a souvent de
l'atlas qui m'habite aujourd'hui et qui
habite chacune des femmes amazir depuis
la nuit des temps
avec toute ma gratitude pour toutes ces
femmes kim entend donner pour elle en
hommage à qui elles sont pour vous voici
tha
m
[Musique]
à
et
les cas les meilleurs
m
et de les payer
[Musique]
l'ailé
m
[Musique]
et
mallat
mal aimé
m
[Musique]
elle aimait
et
[Musique]
ma
les faits
[Musique]
il ment
[Rires]
à malley
elle est
mallet
[Musique]
allez
m
mallet
et
oh
mallet
[Musique]
elle
mais les
elle est
elle
et mai
l'ailé
elle
[Musique]
et les
mais les
les
et
il est
m
miley
bell
l'ailé
mais les les
[Musique]
m
et
mais elle
m
mallet
et là
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]